inician las celebraciones litúrgicas de
la décima Navidad del Papa Francisco en
el Vaticano Después de tres años de
restricciones sanitarias el pontífice
retoma este año el calendario navideño
sin mascarillas y sin límites de
participantes a la ceremonias recordemos
de que la pandemia canceló los baños de
masas los abrazos del Papa a enfermos y
a niños este año en cambio Francisco
retomará el contacto directo con los
fieles en esta Navidad uno de los
momentos más significativos para los
1200 millones de Católicos en el mundo
que celebran el nacimiento de Jesús un
evento que el papa invita a vivir en un
espíritu de sobriedad y de humildad
tomando ejemplo en la extrema pobreza en
la cual según la tradición católica
nació el niño Jesús un mensaje que el
papa seguramente reiterará durante la
misa de gallo la misa de Nochebuena que
se llevará a cabo en la Basílica de San
Pedro esta noche en el Vaticano